can we talk about the melania thing real
quick which which molly thing the the
tape
oh where she was like trying to rescue
the immigrant immigrant yeah they
attacked her for it they're you know
what man she said like 50 different
things like i don't want to be doing
things on christmas
you know it's like i'm paraphrasing here
i think that she
believes that it's a waste of taxpayer
money and time
you know uh but you know like
decorating the white house in in
christmas stuff which nobody likes
anyway they're always like it's so stark
you know and you're like well she took
the time to do it and if you don't like
it then she doesn't have to do it
and now they're like she doesn't want to
do it she's terrible
yeah you know what really bothers me
with the melania stuff is that
she's not trump like she's not donald
okay
she is her own person we're not electing
her yeah and she seems very lovely
she like i understand why people are mad
at trump and stuff but melania doesn't
do anything she like
i i mean like in terms of attacking
people and being nasty or mean or
getting arguments
she's very nice and well-mannered and
quiet she seems like a very
classy person yeah and and they they
were like she ripped out the rose garden
you're not really mad about that
shut up stop okay it's like
the craziest thing to me when i see
these people say like ivanka is such an
awful person i'm like
what wait no look i understand why
you're mad at trump
the donald i understand why because he
says things and he makes crude jokes and
comments
and he's off the cuff but the rest of
like
you look don jr he can be a bombastic
personality but he's not part of the
administration
right right right now right but like
ivanka seems very nice
i don't know she's doing it for free
it's such it's it's
i think that is there's two things that
happened recently that really do
show you the anger and and and
mean-spirited nature these people have
is not legitimate
the first is the obvious the entire time
bashing melania and bashing ivanka
melania melania of all of the people
involved
should does not deserve any of this i
understand ivanka advises
donald and she's involved melania is the
first lady but
what has she done is she like on camera
attacking people and screaming
is she no she like decorated and it
became like a thing well she wore
a jacket that was owning the lips
according to her yeah
which just makes me love her it's more
but but it wasn't what did it say don't
you said something like don't you really
care i really don't care do you
yeah yeah yeah it was and it's not like
it was made specifically for that
situation it was like something she got
at h
m exactly it was like it was a common
thing that people she just
like and she was just like you know what
i'm gonna wear this because
um watch this watch watch this so
i'm getting bored with that i i saw a
meme post where it was like
what it said something like there's no
there's no
you know what was it the socks the cat
or whatever i don't know bill clinton's
dog or something
patches or whatever right they were like
there's no dog at the white house
no cat no children running and opening
christmas presents what has happened to
our country
instead of planting a garden our first
lady destroys it
and i was like what are you talking
about
it's so crazy the rose garden thing to
me was really interesting because they
were looking in the shrubbery literally
in the shrubbery and they're like look
at this pattern oh
this is
whistle if you're looking for that man i
feel like it's because
it's because the the shrubs were at an
angle like an arrow yeah but then
there's
also an outline so they were like it
says kkk
that's right she's not she melania where
she from slovenia is that where she's
from
slovenia like this is insane stuff okay
so that's the first
the second thing is scott adams did a
periscope after the debate and he's like
trump
lost my vote so you know what these
leftists did they started threatening
and insulting him and attacking him
you won you won you got him this big
well-known persuasive trump supporter
has come out angry and instead of saying
come over here brother let me get you a
beer you started
screaming in his face so then scott
tweets i'm voting for trump again
because these people are so nasty and
i'm like that's that that you know what
man
when people talk about trump's attitude
as like a turn off and stuff i hear you
but i'll take the one nasty guy over the
horde of nasty guys
you know what i mean so if there's no
redemption on the left cancel culture
and this far left whatever i i i don't
wanna i don't i don't wanna step foot in
that castle i don't wanna go anywhere
near those people
because they're all nasty now donald
trump can say nasty things
he's not that bad in terms of even his
character he's got character defects for
sure
but i can sit in the right wing pub as a
liberal and they'll buy me a beer
and they'll laugh and be like ah man
you're so wrong about these policies man
but you know getting along is more
important
i that you know that's a good point
because
you know on my personal facebook you
know i have a whole bunch of friends
that have no
idea what i do that you're secretly a
white you supporter
and uh and look they have they have
their views
whether they're misguided or or just uh
very triggered i still i still
respect these people i you know i'm i'm
like i'm still
if i saw them i wouldn't be like ah
you're so stupid
you know i would i would be i would i
would i would respect
their like i just respect them as people
yeah but if i came out and was like um
yeah i'm voting for trump again
i'd just be like unfriended you know
like my
my whole thing and and it's
you know i when when i did my last man
industry
i was being i was being very nice people
were like wow he's just being really
nice to those
biden voters and like well you know it's
like well first of all i feel sorry for
them
no i'm kidding but i like i'm i'm i'm
not
when i when i do that kind of thing i'm
not trying to own them i'm not trying to
like
i tricked you you know um
but it but yeah it it's another i've
seen i've seen stuff where
people are welcomed into these circles
like or they're like
hey this is it's just a you know
african-american guy
um like you trump voters you hate
african-americans right like no
come like they have have some water did
you did you see that video where the
infowars lady
is talking to this black dude and she's
like come on over she's like what do you
think i think that was the one i saw
yeah she's like come on over to the
trump supporters and see what's going on
and he basically says i don't agree with
none of this but you know i want to see
what it's all all about and then they
hug him and they shake his hand
one lady gives him a kiss on the cheek
and she's like yeah as long as we get
along and we're all americans
he looks at this woman and he goes he
gets the kiss on the cheek and he's like
oh man if that's what's going on in
there i'm down
she's like let's go to the other side
and see what happens and then you and
then she goes over there and she says
she's a trump support and they're
screaming and then you just see the
guy's
face like go blank like what is
happening
and it's kind of sad like it is people
are very
people republicans are very tolerant
people you know
um they want to be left alone a lot you
know what i mean
this is where i think a lot of that
polling comes from when
you know peop you you get a call on your
landline and you're like
are you voting for biden or trump you're
like i don't need
any trouble lady i'm just gonna
just joe biden
you know yeah yeah i think like the
there's a lot of self-loathing going on
on the democrats side
since the wikileaks came out with
hillary kind of upending bernie and then
them coming out with a candidate like
joe biden that people don't even like
they're just voting
against trump so they like they don't
even like themselves they don't they
don't
man respect their candidates so that
they have all this bubbling anger that
they end up taking out on people that
aren't in their party do these people
smoke pot
hopefully i should i i don't i
you know i've i've i don't drink i don't
smoke no tattoos nothing i'm very boring
but there's like you gotta chill man
like where are those hippies at to like
sit them down and be like brother
problem
it just accentuates how you're feeling
so if you're angry and you smoke pot you
get angrier
but i don't literally mean it i'm just
saying like y'all need to sit back
like dude is it really the craziest
thing to me
is that there was so i i did a segment
uh today for my main channel there's a
guy
named thomas friedman he's a new york
times columnist and he was telling
anderson cooper that we're on the verge
of a second civil war oh tim said it
because it's a meme but i'm like so this
this guy's telling anderson cooper and
anderson cooper is like do you really
believe that he's like
yes it's happening here i'm like bro do
you really think the world is ending
because of donald trump you need to sit
down crack open a bud light
just watch some family guy yeah man oh
i'm sorry that's too offensive for you
now i don't know what do they watch
these days modern family
just have a good laugh at some sitcom
and situational thing that's the
progressive show right
yeah like that yeah okay good i'm all
right there you go just just
calm down take somebody to take their
phones away yes
and give them just a week with no
internet and watch all of this just go
away
oh yeah i like that that's that's
actually a good point that um can can
you just imagine
i was talking to my dad about um uh
the i was like what what would have
happened if social media existed during
the vietnam war
you know uh because everything is so
amplified
by i'm sure the people were very angry
about
about being in vietnam and or you know
just
hating all of that uh i mean can you
just imagine
if twitter existed back then or facebook
and then people are
always conspiracy theories and and uh oh
we hate the president
or you know we're wishing for his death
that's freaky man that's freaky stuff
that is
that kind of stuff is first of all it's
not helpful
at all it's not helpful it's like
because you're just you're just
gonna make the other side the opposite
side
angry two it's just vile and
and the fact that that twitter is so
selective
about who they who they punish
you know for somebody somebody says one
thing against the president
uh that that's vile like that like dies
you know it's like
and they're very explicit about it it's
like no that's bad
that's that's something that's very
reportable right but
but you know and then you report him
it's like nah it's fine you know i
i think uh i wonder
is jack dorsey evil okay so i've met him
obviously i've talked to him i've had
conversations on
several occasions um but even like since
when i was on rogan i've talked to him
periodically
and the reason why i think that he's not
a good person
is that what he built and what is
currently happening in his name
is a machine that generates hate that's
what twitter is
twitter is not this magical device that
shares information
it it gamifies being
a mean person so you'll see this now the
pundits
like the craziest thing to me when you
see these journalists all of a sudden
there was there's this one dude who was
making fun of me a guy i've never said a
bad word about
and i dm'd him because i know i'm like i
don't understand like because he's
clearly a progressive
and i was like why were you insulting me
in this way i've never said a mean thing
about you
like i'm confused no response
it's because when you say so this person
is a dumb
piece of garbage what a [ __ ] lolol
you get retweets you get likes so it
creates a whole it creates a whole genre
the reply guy
there are people who make six figures
and i mean they make six figures
because what they do is they'll they
they wait they keep refreshing trump's
twitter feed
until trump tweets something and trump
will be trump will say something like
fake news exclamation point
and they'll comment the only thing fake
about the news right now
is the fact that your hair is on it when
they talk about you and then they get a
thousand retweets and likes and then
they go hey thanks for the support
here's my paypal
and it works so people have monetized
and gamified
hatred on twitter facebook not so much
facebook you if you post something like
this person's a
dick people on facebook aren't going to
hit share they're going to be like
well that's weird on twitter though you
screen grab someone's picture you say
what an ugly [ __ ]
and then it gets shared like crazy and
reaching and everyone's piling on and
laughing
twitter is literally a two giant
mobs that are running around smashing
windows and screaming at the top of
their lungs
non-stop and it's escalating and getting
crazier to the benefit of the
republicans
twitter bans them you know why that's a
benefit not to the republican
who gets banned but because twitter is
extremely strict
only the most clean cut and respect you
know respected looking individuals
stay on twitter there are um
even respectable and normal
conservatives who get banned
so what you get is you have two groups
one and there's a left and there's a
right and then you have wingnut crazy
leftists and you have wingnut crazy
right wingers
the right wingers are gone the wingnuts
they banned all of the fringe elements
of the right
so all you have left now are like
run-of-the-mill legal observer like like
lawyers and you know business people
support the president but on the left
you literally have antifa organizing
violence and riots but that infects the
mainstream leftists too
so when the only conversations among the
right are like well i believe donald
trump's tax doesn't go too far enough
and then
you end up with um that's not a real
policy i'm just making a joke you end up
with a leftist
where you'll get some you know fringe
auntie of a person wishing death upon
a political figure then that gets
reached like crazy
and the mainstream leftist sees it and
says that's what people want
and then they return in kind the same
kind of vitriolic nonsense
and vile garbage then the democratic
politicians step in
and they see this is what the left is
talking about and they
they go for it they go for it so i think
the fact that the social media companies
are biased is actually constraining
the right in a good way while it's bad
for the individual
and people shouldn't be getting banned
this way as a collective
they're actually looking cleaner and
more respectable than the left
i think that's why many liberals are
like i'm a conservative now and then
jumping over
because they see these conservatives
that are like normal looking
clean cut respectable and they see a
left that's off the rails
is spitting uh you know vile and victory
garbage at melania
and at regular people you know
i really hate some of these
uh users on twitter that it's they're
it's like you said you know they they
wait for trump to say something like
they
they they basically their job is twitter
full-time
mm-hmm they make a lot of like like um
like defiant brooklyn dad or
or mrs crassenstein
yeah i'm so sure i'm so sure
and and and you like the second the
trump
you're right it's you're exactly right
uh and i don't know how they're making
money i think they
after they get a viral tweet they they
link their paypal okay
well then they're like paypal me i
hate those people so much i hate them
think
just think about how i have to imagine
these people
after like the day is done and they're
looking at their bank accounts
they start crying you know
could you imagine like in a hundred
years there's like
an encyclopedia wikipedia or whatever or
like neural link knowledge network
and then people are like uh yes brooklyn
dead he's famous for constantly
complaining to president trump
he never could he never contributed
anything of substance other than
generic complaints about trump's general
behavior
but uh he is well known for this and
frowned upon
what have we become that's their legacy
you know you know the story of the nobel
nobel prize prizes that alfred nobel
invented dynamite
and so then someone published his
obituary early and they called him the
merchant of death
and when he saw it he panicked and he
was like is that what i am
so then he immediately was like i gotta
do something better with this and then
created the nobel prize or whatever
i think that's the general story that
that was it right you man i don't know
i think he was also an arms manufacturer
was that maybe how he got i think that
was part of it
i don't but i don't know much about him
but that was it was something like that
so he like panicked because they
accidentally published this
and he realized his legacy was garbage
and he was like i don't want to be that
i don't want people to look back and say
like this is what the person did do that
more
so i wonder these people who are on
twitter man
i'll tell you what dude there's a guy
you know he's a journalist he was a
journalist
and he was an okay journalist and then
he started figuring out that when he
replied to donald trump he started
getting a ton of followers
and he messaged me one day he was like
dude i gained like 5 000 followers like
because i've been tweeting at trump and
i was like bro don't do it man
do not go down this road listen i was
like a lot of people
are just like you're in a crowd of
people screaming and throwing feces at a
wall that's what it is
there's nothing of substance trump isn't
even there
like they think they're yelling at trump
trump's not there in their mind
they're walking up to him and going like
hey man fu trump
which you're allowed to do by all means
but in reality you walk up to a brick
wall with a picture of trump's face on
it and you're screaming and you're all
laughing and high-fiving each other
meanwhile the president's doing whatever
he's not reading your comments
i warned him i don't think he can find
work anymore
because i remember there was there was a
couple people i talked to who had gone
down this road
and i was like they're like hey man i'm
really looking for work and wondering
like you know you're doing
your companies are doing well i'm
wondering and i was like bro i can't
hire you are you crazy
like you're you're you're generating
followers off of just saying
dumb things to trump there's no
substance in what you do
your your resume right now is that
you're a guy who complains to the
president
with generic insults there's no job for
you anymore bro
so some of these people actually deleted
their accounts no joke well here's
here's a question
continuing on with with this legacy what
happens
when when what happens if joe biden wins
i'm gonna laugh first of all i'm gonna
i'm gonna cry for america
uh oh hey dude you gotta you gotta
listen listen listen we're all in this
big boat
and we're going just downstream there's
a waterfall in front of us
there's like a waterfall on one side and
like a category five rapid
it's gonna be bumpy but like ones you
know what man
for those brief seconds as biden gets
elected i'm going to be sitting in the
back of that raft while everyone's
screaming and i'm going to crack that
beer and be like here we go baby
waterfall if fighting wins it will be so
bad
for four years everyone in the country
the people that didn't they hated trump
that didn't want to vote for biden but
did it anyway are going to hate him
so much that anyone can win in 2024.
that'll be interesting uh well okay so
first of all when i say cry for america
uh i don't necessarily mean like for the
republic
or or democracy uh i'm talking about
just like
how dumb people are to be actually
voting for that's why i would laugh
um but i mean yeah and and i think
ultimately it'll be one of those
situations where it's like well
we look back on it and laugh and that's
true uh but what happens to
the washington post what happened what
happens to
well like a look at look what happened
with the washington post where where
they
they basically built an entire
journalistic team
to investigate trump like that's their
job that's all they do
you think they're going to have one for
biden nope no no of course
you know ryan long right yes so uh he
for those unfamiliar he's a comedian we
had him on the show he's hilarious but
he did a segment uh skit
where it was like it's a it's a news
room and they're sitting around it's
election night and they're like
bride and harris yeah and then it's like
a month later and they're all sweating
and like what do we write about
there's nothing to do what do we write
what did we write about before i don't
even remember
that's all they do now and what's what's
really funny is
what people don't realize is i think if
trump doesn't win
they're gonna they're gonna keep going
oh there's gonna they're gonna find a
fill-in for what trump
is so they're gonna say like the
alt-right or something like they've
they've done before that's what they'll
go for and
i mean they're they they can't give up
the machine you know what i mean they've
created it but then what happens to
all these personalities or or
whatever you know like uh mrs
krasenstein
that just makes me funny it makes me
laugh
uh like what what happened like hold on
for people who don't know it's because
there was originally two guys called the
krasenstein brothers who would reply to
trump all the time and they got banned
and now they were manipulating the
numbers of their followers apparently
i don't know i don't believe that i
really don't i think why would they get
banned
why would milo yiannopoulos get banned
for the same reason
milo yiannopoulos got banned they said
multiple accounts they say that about
everybody yeah it sounds like it sounds
like bunk bs
so i don't know why they got banned i'm
not going to accuse them if twitter
doesn't release evidence then as far as
i'm concerned twitter can't prove
anything
okay that's fair but these guys just
reply to trump all the time get banned
also their wives pop up
or like the wife pops up or something is
that the mother yeah and if you look at
it
it's the mother i think it's mother and
if you look at the profile picture of
mrs krasenstein this is like the the
deadest eyes
oh i don't want to wrap wearing wearing
a mask that says uh
biden 2020 or whatever i think i'm
pretty sure it
is like someone helen steen
yeah yeah that's what made me think it
was the mom oh the mom
i don't know i but i i doubt that this
person
is actually who they say they are that's
my point you know what really bothers me
about a lot of this is that
i can't i think not like it was joe
biden said you know can you imagine not
having to think about donald trump ever
again
or something like that's a part of his
campaign like it'll be over close your
eyes no no no hold on hold on
you don't get to scream as loud as
possible in my face
donald trump while bashing me over the
head with like a foam hammer
and then you're like don't you want it
to stop don't you want it to stop
just make me president and it'll stop
i'm like no yeah
i'm gonna be like okay donald trump
punch this guy in the face and get him
out of my face
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give you
power because you've been screaming at
me for
four years dude the new york times won
two pulitzers
for russia gate that kills me
it's not even real like dude you know
what's funny
people are like well they won pulters
because they covered the story as it was
known at the time
here's my description of this if i said
to somebody i would like to pay you 100
to mow my lawn and they go you got it
champ and then an hour later i walk
outside and the guy across the street
from me has his
his lawn mowed i'd be like you did an
amazing job
award-winning even but it's not my lawn
you did the wrong
job you can say the journalism was great
and they investigated
and they did the wrong thing it's like
if i said would you could you carry this
you know
sack of heavy stones into my basement
and then they walk off and carry it a
mile away i'm like well you carried it a
lot
farther than i wanted you to but i have
no idea where you were going or why
but good job good job yeah good job yeah
i'm you know award-winning
you no but you know you know what really
happens
it's like i hired this guy to mow my
lawn i come out an hour later my
neighbor's lawn is mowed
and then his buddy walks over and goes
whoa good job here's an award and high
fives him
that's what the pulitzer prizes they're
rewarding themselves for like
just they're not even covering a real
story could you imagine if they
actually investigate and they're like
whoa this is fake
instead and nobody nobody calls on the
times to go um
you know you kind of got all that wrong
you should
maybe give that thing back you know just
journalistic integrity
maybe maybe the iraq war was the time
they should have like you know
hung their tie up and said well america
we uh
we've been set up yeah i mean i don't
even look they they gave um
give a rap album pulitzer really
yeah they gave um oh what's his name
was it common not common no no um
you guys know i'm in the chat the chat's
gonna light up they're gonna be like we
know it is
yeah it's um i mean i mean
it was a good album like that i can't
remember the name of
pulitzer prizes
i'm like really like no but that's
normal yeah it goes to broadcast it goes
to music
yeah but i'm just i'm just saying like
how do you win an award for like fake
news
and then brag about it and then they
announced we're going to shift from
trump and russia to trump and racism and
then
whoop now all of a sudden everything's
trump's racist well
and then it went and then it went to you
know trump and
covet and then trump back back to trump
and racism
so it they're throwing everything at the
wall
except the kitchen sink seeing what
sticks
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time